bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette anatomie comparaît pour les
nuls et les aliens et non pas avec des
aliens cette fois petite anatomie
comparer pour les nuls où on va s'amuser
en fait il va pas s'agir de débloquer le
contenu qu'on va regarder aujourd'hui
mais il va s'agir de s'amuser un petit
peu de jouer à un petit jeu et ce petit
jeu c'est le petit jeu de comment les
extraterrestres aurrez aurre visualiser
les animaux terriens juste à partir de
leur crâne donc comment les
extraterrestres aurait imaginé on va
dire les animaux terriens juste en se
basant sur leurs crânes et ça va être
l'occasion justement de faire un petit
peu d'anatomie comparée de jouer le jeu
et de voir justement comment on
reconstruit un animal est un à partir
justement de son de l'anatomie de son
crâne donc le mieux pour comprendre ce
jeu est ce qu'on va faire c'est encore
de commencer immédiatement et on va
commencer du coup avec ce crâne alors ce
crâne c'est un crâne de petits
carnivores comme vous pouvez le voir les
grandes canines nous l'indiquons a aussi
ici les molaires donc d'ailleurs c'est
un mammifère puisqu'on a des incisives
des canines et des molaires déjà on va
commencer par le basic est sûre ce crâne
de ce qu'on peut voir donc c'est que la
dentition est plutôt carnivores on a des
grosses incisive des grosses canine on a
des démos l'air qui sont plutôt pointu
avec notamment une dominance ici d'une
molaire en eau et d'une autre mot l'air
en bas qui nous suggère qu'il s'agit
d'un carnivore mais du groupe des
mammifères qui s'appelle les carnivores
a donc les mammifères carnivores
appartiennent tous au groupe des
carnivores à et ils ont ce qu'on appelle
un complexe carnassiers l'ailé
carnassière la 4e prémolaires du aulas
est la première molaire du bas et là on
a l'air d'avoir une carnassière est
derrière cette carnassière vous voyez il
n'y a pas de dents sur la mandibule donc
ça c'est typique de ce qu'on rencontre
chez les félidés donc les fnl la famille
des chats et l'a vu la taille de l'oeil
l'oeil est super gros donc on a plutôt
affaire à un petit chat voire même un
très petit chat et je pense qu'il s'agit
tous
ap le mans d'un chat donc voilà vous
pouvez prendre les paris est-ce qu'il
s'agit d'un chat est ce qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un chat tension 3 2 1
c'était bien un achat bon je prends pas
trop de risque non plus un sur ce
coup-là faut bien dire les choses comme
elles sont donc il s'agit bien achats et
que le jeu s'est regardé du coup comment
les aliens aurait reconstitué
alors c'est intéressant c'est
intéressant comme reconstitution alors
qu'est-ce qu'il va pas qu'est ce qui va
pas entre ce crâne et cet alien cette
reconstitution d'un viennent dans déjà
on peut voir ce qui les a conduits à
faire cette reconstitution à savoir les
canines elle est grosse incisive
donc on a effectivement des cannes des
grosses canine et des grosses incisif
puisque comme je dis c'est un carnivore
après le nombre d' assises y faisait
incisive même pas l'air à six le nombre
d'un sixième est plutôt juste non il est
pas juste regarder 1 2 3 1 2 3 4 donc le
nombre d' assises ivan m'balla avait pas
et pas symétrique et en os c'est pareil
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 donc il n'est pas
symétrique un problème donc normalement
chez les carnivores il ya trois incisive
de chaque côté là il ya quatre as is it
dakota et trois de l'autre donc il n'est
pas très très symétriques cet extra en
face ce char constitué par un
extraterrestre dont je pense pas que les
extraterrestres serait serait tombé à ce
point là mais depuis les grosses ouais
les grosses canines sont un peu trop en
avant par rapport à la rangée des des
incisives ça se voit notamment sur la
mandibule là c'est beaucoup trop en
avant par rapport aux canines
après il ya ce qui choque aussi c'est
l'absence de lèvres
l'absence de l'ebre par contre ils ont
eu raison c'est le sur les yeux qui a la
vision binoculaire là pour le coup ils
l'ont bien par contre la taille des yeux
est beaucoup trop petit par rapport au
bon je sais bien que c'est pas vraiment
la reconstitution qu'un alien on aurait
fait évidemment mais le but du jeu c'est
quand même de s'imaginer que c'est
effectivement ce que des aliens aurait
produit et comment il aurait pu
effectivement arriver à un meilleur
résultat
donc l'absence de lèvres l'absence de
nesle ailleurs l'absence de progrès at
his most y ait un visage humain
basiquement donc ya pas deux
il n'y a pas de face il ya pas de museau
donc ça c'est aussi une erreur qui
aurait pu être évitée l'absence de nez
là il ya un trou pour le nez là il
aurait quand même réussi à le voir je le
dire ces aliens
on va quand même être gentil avec eux et
dire qu'il n'était pas bête à ce point
là et oui ce qui va pas donc c'est
l'absence de lèvres alors justement
comment on reconstruit les tissus mous
sur un crâne ça c'est une question qui
revient très souvent
ben déjà on compare avec les espèces
modernes donc quand on a un crâne de
chat par exemple c'est pas trop
compliqué de savoir qu'il y avait des
tissus mous puisqu'on a encore des chats
qui vivent aujourd'hui là où ça devient
un peu plus compliqué c'est quand on a
des espèces qui sont complètement
éteinte et qui n'ont pas de
représentants moderne et donc c'est et
c'est justement ça le jeu avec les
l'histoire des aliens qui essaye de
reconstituer les les espèces modernes
c'est que justement les aliens
ils vont partir du principe que y'a rien
d'équivalent qui existe sur leur planète
donc ils partent complètement en roue
libre mais bon il ya quand même des
choses qui peuvent voir donc la position
des yeux la position du nez la position
de la bouche on va partir du principe
que les aliens sont humanoïdes donc
qu'ils ont à peu près la même
constitution que nous sinon sinon on
s'en sort pas mais comment il aurait pu
savoir qu'il y avait des lèvres par
exemple bon alors déjà déjà il n'y a pas
de jours non plus donc on va commencer
par les joues donc il aurait pu savoir
qu'il y avait des joues parce qu on a
cette fausse ici qui se trouve en
dessous de l'arcade jus galles qui est
la fausse d'insertion pour le muscle
master qui vient s'accrocher là sur la
mâchoire
donc ça ils auraient pu le voir par
exemple ça aurait été assez facile à
voir le muscle master qui vient
s'accrocher up directement ici sur la
mâchoire et là vous voyez cette petite
fosse ici cette petite fosse et
l'insertion des muscles la bio donc des
muscles des lèvres donc c'est pareil on
aurait pu savoir que ici il y avait un
muscle qui passaient d'ailleurs muscles
qui est aussi trahi par la présence de
ce trou qui est le trou pour le nerf
trijumeau est le nerf trijumeau c'est
lui qui donne sa sensibilité aux lèvres
donc s'il ya un air qui sort là pour
aller innervé quelque chose eh ben on
sait qu'il ya quelque chose c'est pas
qui a rien voilà donc là il aurait pu
savoir
qui avait effectivement de la chair à ce
niveau là après on peut s'interroger sur
effectivement la texture de la peau et
là je pense que c'est comme pour les
dinosaures c'est à dire qu'ils sont en
roue libre
enfin les aliens sur les animaux
modernes sont comme nous complètement ou
libre quand on regarde des dinosaures
c'est à dire que les dinosaures on en
est arrivé à un point où décider s'ils
avaient des écailles ou des plumes et où
il avait des écailles ou des plumes ou
se situer ses écailles et ses plumes
ça devient de plus en plus compliqué
donc là là il vit on est typiquement sur
de la spéculation rationnelle c'est à
dire de la spéculation dans la limite du
possible
ça rappelle d'ailleurs un livre qui
s'appelle ollier studies donc qui est un
livre où justement les des palais aux
artistes ont décidé d'écrire un livre
pour justement dénoncé un peu le fait
que ben on manquait un peu d'imagination
sur les fossiles et notamment qu'on on
avait tendance à aller un peu trop à
l'économie d'hypothèses selon eux donc
l'économie d'hypothèses c'est quand même
comme ça que fonctionne la science c'est
à dire que quand on trouve un squelette
on va pas y rajouter plus de choses que
strictement nécessaire puisque sinon bah
voila tu veux dire à force de rajouter
des trucs qu'on finit juste par une
boule de viande 1 si vous avez un
squelette et que vous voulez rajouter
autant de muscles que vous voulez vous
finissez juste avec une grosse boule de
viande mais donc on va à l'économie
d'hypothèses et on ne met que les
muscles pour lesquelles on a une preuve
mais c'est vrai que comme ils ont
dénoncé si on devait faire ça avec les
mammifères d'aujourd'hui baba bois ça
ressemblerait à ça voilà où un chien je
sais plus si c'est un chien ou un
babouin mais là vous voyez un signe ça
ressemblerait à ça si on devait aller à
l'économie d'hypothèses pourquoi pas
parce qu'on n'a pas de trace de plumes
sur les os enfin sur les fossiles on
aurait pas de traces évidentes de plus
ma part éventuellement sur les
avant-bras
mais voilà là par exemple vous avez un
exemple d'appât taurus qui pour lequel
on a imaginé plus qu'on aurait pu voir
sur le fossile est bon bah ça vous
illustre bien que si on se laisse trop
aller ça ça a ses limites quand même ce
raisonnement donc oui il faudrait qu'on
soit plus imaginatif il faudrait qu'on
rajoute plus de viande
plus de chair à certains endroits
notamment sur le crâne sur le crâne on a
tendance voilà on a tendance à dessiner
les les dinosaures justement avec les
fausses temporal apparente et même la
fosse
ils ont une forte orbitaire apparente
donc là pour le coup c'est un chien non
c'est un chat pardon c'est un chat
autant pour moi donc là pour le coup
c'est censé être un chat avec sa vision
binoculaire basse à répondre directement
à ça du coup là on a un chat et on a sa
vision binoculaire mais comme on sait
pas si on doit lui mettre de la peau ou
des écailles balla ils lui ont mis des
écailles il leur construit comme un
dinosaure en fait ils ont mis des
écailles et les fausses temporal ils ont
juste mis des écailles d'une couleur
différente et avec un peu profondes
au lieu de mettre un muscle et du coup
que la fosse temporal ne soit pas
apparentes sur le crâne comme c'est le
cas chez les chats moderne vous ne voyez
pas l'emplacement de la fosse temporal
sur votre chat ben là ils ont mis des
écailles et un petit renfoncement comme
on fait chez les dinosaures
donc parce qu on y va parce qu'on va à
l'économie d'hypothèses à l'économie de
viande et du coup quand on économise
beaucoup la viande basse on vous fait un
trou dont classe et voilà c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont dénoncé un peu leur truc
c'est qui ça manquait un peu
d'imagination tout ça voilà donc
hollister days
voilà c'est le titre du bouquin si ça
vous intéresse si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur comment on reconstitue les les
les dinosaures et les espèces éteintes
en général voilà c'est le livre qu'il
vous faut donc c'est exactement
l'exercice auquel on va se prêter
aujourd'hui finalement donc le suivant
voici le crâne c'est un crocodile n'ya
pas à tortiller c'est un crocodile la
surface déjà le long museau la surface
qui est ponctué de petits trous
la fosse mandibulaire qui indique que
c'est un archosaures ici les archosaures
ont une fausse mandibulaire c'est qu'une
fo-santé orbiteur mais là il n'y a pas
de faux santé orbitaire parce que c'est
un crocodile et que c'est un trait
distinctif des crocodiles des trains
archosaures sans fo santé orbitaire la
petite barre à l'arrière de l'oeil
d'oncle orbite est ici la petite barre à
l'arrière de l'oeil qui et renfoncer
dans le crâne ça c'est typique des
crocodiles aussi et je sais que c'est un
crocodile est pas un alligator parce que
les dents sont se croisent en fait donc
les dents du dessus croiser les dents du
dessous alors que chez un alligator les
dents du dessus recouvre complètement
les dents du dessous comme chez nous en
fait et l'alligator aussi un museau un
peu plus rond un peu plus régulier donc
voici bon ça c'est pas trop au dessus
comment un alien ne reconstituera animal
oui c'est pas mal c'est pas mal du tout
ces petits traits d'humour petits traits
d'humour alors le suivant
bon oui alors ça je vois je vois où ils
veulent en venir avec ça donc ça c'est
un crâne humain c'est un crâne humain
mais en fait c'est un juvénile
donc il ya des dents de qui a les dents
de de l'est encore en place et qui a les
dents adultes qui sont en dessous en
train de pousser et en fait ils ont
enlevé le l'os maxillaire ellos
mandibulaire pour qu'on puisse voir les
dents en fait donc un crâne de d'enfants
cela ressemble pas à ça en réalité c'est
juste si vous enlevez l'os qui cache les
dents c'est ce que vous voyez en fait
vous voyez les dents de remplacement les
dents adultes qui vont qui sont en train
de pousser en dessus des dents de lait
et effectivement ça donne cet aspect
super effrayant
[Rires]
comment les aliens constituerait ce
crâne oui c'est à peu près ça oui
humain avec une dentition de requins
c'est à peu près ça l'idée c'est à peu
près ça l'idée est donc le vrai animal
le vrai animal le plus terrible au monde
le gamin numéro 4 ah bah ça c'est un sas
est un cas intéressant évidemment vous
pouvez mettre la vidéo sur pause si vous
voulez pas que je vous spoiler la
réponse à chaque fois donc le numéro 4
alors on a ici un animal avec des yeux
qui ressorte sur le dessus donc c'est un
animal semi aquatique
on a des incisives des canines des
molaires c'est un mammifère donc un
mammifère aquatique et on ad énormes
défense là donc c'est un hippopotame
y'a pas à tortiller avec des défenses de
cette taille y compris des défenses au
niveau des incisives l'hippopotame c'est
le seul mammifère qui à dd qui a non
seulement des défenses au niveau des
canines mais aussi des défenses au
niveau des incisives donc
donc c'est à peu près ça à peu près sûr
qu'on est face à un hippopotame en
regardant ça et puis il ya la mâchoire
qui a ce crochet ici au niveau de la
mandibule crochet qui est très important
puisque ça permet à l'hippopotame
d'ouvrir grand la bouche sans se couper
la carotide
avec ce bout d'os cela s'il n'y avait
pas ce crochet là ici cette petite
petite fosse l'a en fait ça couperet la
carotide à chaque fois qu'il ouvre grand
la bouche donc le l'hippopotame les
hippopotames sont connus pour ouvrir
très très grand la bouche a presque 180
degrés ils appellent ça le bâillement
c'est un rituel amoureux et donc ça
évite de se couper la circulation du
sang dans le cerveau
donc ça c'est un hippopotame typiquement
alors comment on reconstitue rsa ainsi
en étaient à un alien bien évidemment
oui c'est monstrueux en hip hop et en
plus ils ont pris la photo genre de
l'hippopotame le plus inoffensif du
monde
bon les hippopotames c'est quand même
les mammifères les plus dangereux au
monde
c'est d'ailleurs même plus dangereux que
les crocodiles pas seulement les
mammifères mais c'est même plus
dangereux que les crocodiles ou les
requins il ya plus de morts par
hippopotames chaque année que de mort
par par crocodile et aux ricains donc
c'est un petit peu mensonger cette image
quand même demont
le le gentil ni pau en train de dormir
mais bref
oui ça c'est tout aussi faux évidemment
donc ouais c'est intéressant du coup de
voir que en fait ils proposeraient
évidemment un animal supposément
carnivores très méchant il des tout
petits yeux bien vicieux alors que là on
a quand même des gros yeux des gros yeux
tout ronds donc il ya alors à part la
position des yeux qui a un peu trop
basse là vous voyez que les orbites
elles font vraiment saillie au dessus du
crâne un donc là les orbites sont un peu
trop basses elles sont un peu trop en
position normale quoi en fait
donc ce finalement elle serait pas si
fausse cette reconstruction
alors on va commencer d'avant en arrière
donc évidemment le nez le nez qui est
recouvert complètement de cherché
d'hippopotames qu'il a été complètement
à nu et là vous voyez le nez est ici
donc le net à l'homme est à une position
qu'on considérait assez spontané pour
déjà vous voyez cette barre qui sépare
les deux narines elles n'existent pas
sur l'hippopotame
donc ça c'est plutôt un truc de reptiles
qu'on a collé à l'hippopotame donc je
vois pas pourquoi les extraterrestres
aurait fait ça l'est dans vos balais
dans elles sont bon endroit quoi la
question c'est du coup comment on sait
que l'ipo comment on pourrait savoir que
l'hippopotame avait autant de viande sur
le nez et donc ne ressemblait pas à ça
et la réponse la réponse des réponses y
en a plusieurs
d'une comme pour le chat on a ici
l'insertion des muscles delà des muscles
la bio et qui est très très profonde
vous voyez chez le chat s'était à peine
visible mais là c'est très profond chez
l'hippopotame donc on a des gros muscles
la bio et on a ici de très gros foramen
encore une fois pour le nerf trijumeau
donc donc qui devait innervé par
définition quelque chose donc il n'y
avait pas au moins on saurait qui avait
pas rien comme ce qu'ils ont fait là
déjà on se serait pas juste contenté de
coller la peau à cet endroit là ensuite
ensuite commence à voir la quantité de
chair en général ça ça par contre ça
aura été relativement difficile il ya il
ya quelque chose qu'on aurait pu savoir
c'est effectivement si oui ou non il y
avait de la chaire qui recouvrait les
dents parce que les grosses gencives des
grosses gencives comme ça ça laisse des
marques
enfin justement ça laisse pas de marque
c'est à dire que les traces d'usure sur
les dents ne seraient pas les mêmes là
où il y avait là là où il y avait les
grosses lèvres que qui recouvrait les
dents que là où il y en avait pas donc
ça on aurait pu le savoir au niveau des
traces il ya l'endroit où les dents
étaient protégés par les lèvres on
aurait pu dire bon ben ok on aurait pu
tracer une ligne en disant voilà les
lèvres elle allait au moins jusque là et
récemment on a aussi fait ça avec des
théropodes c'est que on a analysé les
isotopes des dents donc la géochimie des
dents est en fait parce que les danses
et du minerai enfin c'est du minéral
cessé de l'émail les maïs et phosphate
de calcium c'est mais bref ça reste un
minéral donc on analyse des isotopes et
en fait on se rend compte que là où il
n'y a pas de lèvres les isotopes sont la
signature isotopique est différente de
là où il y a des lèvres et donc c'est à
partir de sacs chez les théropodes ils
ont fait l'hypothèse que peut-être les
théropodes avait des lèvres des petites
lèvres comme les com comme on voit chez
certains les arts un pas pas des grosses
lèvres bien charnues pas comme dans
jurassic park là des grosses lèvres
charnues comme celle et raptor là qu'ils
arrivent à bouger
on n'est pas sur des lèvres musculeuse
comme chez les mammifères on est sur des
lèvres juste qui recouvre les dents en
fait c'est juste à leur repli de peau
qui recouvre les dents donc donc on
pourrait savoir si oui ou non il y avait
de la chair par dessus mais par contre
savoir qu'il y avait tout ça de chair ce
serait difficile on pourrait
raisonnablement en faire l'hypothèse
tout simplement parce que la position
des yeux les yeux indique que l'animal
donc se tenait à la surface avec les
yeux qui sortait de l'eau c'est pour ça
que les yeux sont l'air de sortir comme
ça du crâne vers le haut c'est à
l'animal qui se tient à la surface avec
juste les yeux qui sortent et du coup
ils auraient pu faire l'hypothèse que du
coup cette narines là s'il n'y a pas de
chair qui permet à la narine des taux
orientés vers le haut en fait cette
narines ce serait ouverte sous l'eau là
comme sable si vous mettez le niveau de
l'eau à ce niveau là voilà la narine
s'ouvre sous l'eau et puis c'est mort
quoi l'animal se noie alors que celle
hippopotames vous voyez qu'il ya de la
ja de la viande sur le museau et que
grâce à cette viande en fait la narine
et tourné vers le haut comme ça comme ça
les narines sont au dessus du niveau de
l'eau au même niveau que les yeux donc
ils ont
plus imaginez quand même ces
extraterrestres vu qu'on ait cette phase
un animal semi-aquatique alors les
narines aurait dû être orientés vers le
haut et que pour y arriver il faut de la
viande parce que sans la viande il a le
nez sous la flotte
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'ils
auraient pu faire les extraterrestres et
la corne ici donc là c'est très
intéressant acquise les reconstituer ce
processus itie donc le crochet de la
mâchoire comme étant une corne
ce crochet la ccc à la muscle
masticatoire ici qui s'insèrent l'a donc
le le muscle master qui va s'accrocher
jusque-là aulas en dessous de l'arcade
jeu galles énorme muscles master et on
voit que c'est une insertion de muscles
quel que soit le muscle en question on
voit que c'est une assertion de muscle
parce que c'est une fausse a donc le
muscle sincères et l'a donc là
normalement il devrait pas se dire que
il ya une corne ici d'autant que
généralement quand il a une corne la
surface elle est recouverte de petits de
petites ponctuation de petits vaisseaux
sanguins bref il faut des trucs pour
alimenter la corne la corne c'est de la
kératine qui pousse donc il faut deux il
faut de l'alimentation pour cette corne
donc souvent la surface est pas lisse
comme ça elle devrait être rugueuse et
recouverte de petits vaisseaux sanguins
de traces de petits vaisseaux sanguins
et puis ils ont réparé constitué ça
comme un gros carnivores vindicatif tout
simplement parce que les dents les
molaires sont typiquement dédain de deux
d'herbivores ce sont des dents un
couronne très haute et à surfaces plates
qui sert à qui servent à mastiquer de
l'herbe
donc je pense que les extraterrestres
aurait été plus mal accès pour le coup
il aurait été je pense plus malin que ça
a le suivant ça
ensemble oui alors ça ressemble
effectivement à achraf de crâne d'alien
avec le long tuyau et puis les grandes
dents alors en plus ils ont mis les
dents bien en avant la bouche bien
ouverte donc encore une fois grosse
incisif grosse canine on est sur un
carnivore il ya une différence entre
incisif canine molaires on est sur la
même île faire mammifère carnivore
on devrait trouver une carnassière c'est
le cas vous avez ici une carnassiers en
haut une carnation emballe la
carnassière en bas est bien visible
parce que là elle est visiblement plus
grosse que toutes les autres et puis
après c'est là c'est surtout le fait que
la carnassière soit pas très tranchante
déjà va nous indiquer qu'on est plutôt
du côté chien ou ours de la phylogénie
des carnivores la phylogénie t
carnivores c'est pas compliqué vous avez
la famille deschiens vous avez la
famille des chats les chiens et les ours
sont dans la même famille et les chats
et les hyènes sont dans l'autre famille
et leurs dents sont très différentes il
y en a qui ont les dents qui coupent et
l'autre qui ont les dents qui coupent
donc la vue qu'on a des dents qui n'ont
pas l'air d'être très très affûté on est
plutôt je pense du côté des chiens et en
plus on a une dent derrière la
carnassière ce qui indique ce qui
confirmerait qu'on est du côté des
chiens donc on est du côté des cas ni
forme et après c'est surtout une
question de
c'est surtout une question d'habitude
mais on a déjà une boîte crânienne qui
est très allongé qui est un truc qu'on
rencontre chez les ch et les pinnipèdes
dont chez des phoques et les otaries et
là vous avez une grosse une grosse
truffe un gros trou pour le museau avec
qui est pas tout à fait en position
terminal donc et pas tout à fait alignés
on va dire avec la surface ici dupré
maxillaire vous avez cette petite
rétraction et cette petite rétraction ça
indique un animal semi-aquatique donc je
dirais que ça impuni peine et à prêcher
les pinnipèdes vous avez les otaries et
les phoques et les morses bon c'est
évidemment pas un morse puisque sinon on
aurait si les énormes défense encore que
les femelles n'ont pas mais bon je veux
dire de la crâne du le crâne d'une
femelle mort c'est comme un mal morse
mais sans les défenses donc c'est c'est
quand même très reconnaissable les
otaries ont une espèce de casque est au
dessus des yeux là et là je vois pas de
casquette donc je dirais que c'est une
otarie alors on va voir ce que c'est
comment les aliens oui je vois comment
les aliens reconstruit rsa comme ban et
xénomorphes la longueur du crâne comme
ça vers l'arrière c'est intéressant
après les xénomorphes n'ont pas d'yeux
et là il ya des orbites donc
donc je dirais pas que que ça ressemble
énormément et xénomorphes et encore une
fois on à l'absence de lèvres ici on a
un très très gros foramen voyez pour le
passage d'une ère trijumeau avec une
très très profondes fosses ici pour les
lèvres pour le muscle labiale donc
encore une fois selon lui mettrais des
lèvres quand même on y mettrait des
lèvres et puis en plus le xénomorphes il
n'a pas donné non plus donc
donc c'est pas vraiment non c'est pas
c'est pas encore une fois ces données
assez peu de crédit aux scientifiques
aliens que de que de s'imaginer qu'ils
les reconstruire comme ça à et perdu
c'était une autre c'était une loutre à
la disgrâce
la disgrâce oui bah oui une loutre la
disgrâce oui donc très proche oui ça on
reste du côté caennais de la force du
côté des chiens mais le trou ouais
peut-être qu une otarie aurrez aurre le
aurait un trou pour le nez beaucoup plus
gros que ça effectivement
et puis aurait peut-être ah oui je sais
où je me suis fait avoir les dents je me
suis fait avoir les pinnipèdes non plus
de carnassière à la jeu la honte la
honte la honte voilà si vous regardez un
crâne de pinnipèdes un crâne de de
phoques du coup donc le crâne de phoques
à un très très gros trous pour le museau
et surtout les dents sont toutes les
mêmes il ya plus de carnassière bah oui
c'est typique des piscivores la honte la
honte sur moi j'ai perdu j'ai perdu mais
on n'apprend plus en faisant des erreurs
on apprend plus en faisant d or c'est
une erreur que je ne refais la plus
verte chez ce qu'on l'ait trop bas
tracer ma oui bah c'est là c'est le
classique crâne d'éléphants qui est pris
pour un crâne de sites
l'op pour le coup parce que on pense on
s'imagine évidemment que les aliens
devons prendre ça pour le trou de l'oeil
au lieu de prendre ces trous là pour les
trous des yeux donc mais oui
effectivement c'est un grand classique
c'est un grand classique même bien il ya
déjà des spécialistes qui ont supposé
que les légendes les récits et les
légendes de cyclope venait de la
découverte de crâne d'éléphants n'a donc
les éléphants nains qui vivaient sur les
îles méditerranéennes au quaternaire
donc ils ont ils ont proposé qu'en fait
la légende des cyclopes venait de la
découverte de crâne d'éléphants d'agde
dont le nez en fait la cavité nasale
avaient été mal interprétés comme comme
étant la qualité de l'oeil d'un oeil
unique alors que la cavité de l'oeil se
trouve là et bon après c'est vrai qu'ils
ont ils ont quand même une tête bizarre
les éléphants c'est dur de s'imaginer
que ça c'est la qualité d'une haie alors
que le bout du museau et là en fait et
c'est parce que là en fait vous avez
cette fausse ici c'est l'insertion des
muscles de la trompe donc est ici vous
avez encore une fois le trou du nerf
trijumeau qui vous indiquent qu'il y
avait beaucoup de viande à l'avant voyez
la taille d'une ère trijumeau elle est
presque aussi grand il est presque aussi
grand club donc ce nerf trijumeau il
vous indique qu'il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de viande alors un extra
terrestre serait normalement capables de
voir qu'il y avait quelque chose ici non
pas comme eux ce qu'ils ont fait là mais
est-ce qu'ils seraient capables d'aller
jusqu'à imaginer qu'il y avait une
trompe ce serait compliqué ce serait
compliqué parce que même pour les
éléphants fossiles enfin pour les
proches parents des éléphants fossiles
et les proboscidiens fossiles on n'a
aucune idée de ce à quoi leurs trompes
ressemblait donc là pour le coup il
recouvrir est peut-être tout ça d'une
belle boule de chair éventuellement qui
évidemment communiquerait avec le nez
ici
on pourrait être sûr que ça c'est le nez
puisque après quand vous suivez vous
pouvez glisser votre main là en fait
c'est suffisamment grand et vous finirez
par atteindre la bouche donc c'est là
qu'habite et du nez il n'y a pas de
doute sur l'interprétation de cette
chose-là donc donc je donnerais quand
même un peu plus de crédit à nos aliens
en disant que mon avis serait quand même
capable de voir que ça c'est la qualité
d'une est tout simplement parce que ça
communique avec la bouche et pas avec
pas avec le cerveau comme le ferait un
oeil donc donc non là encore une fois je
suis pas d'accord avec l'interprétation
est évidemment c'est un éléphant
ceci étant dit ceci est un éléphant
d'asie on peut pas voir si c'est un
éléphant d'asie ou d'afrique normalement
faut regarder les dents mais les
défenses sont plutôt petites donc ça m'a
l'air d'être à juvénile quand même mais
bon même sur un éléphant d'afrique les
défenses devrait être un peu plus grande
donc c'est peut-être un éléphant d'asie
effectivement donc le crâne évidemment
comment les aliens de reconstituer
killer croc
je suis plus gros crocodile donc ça
c'est un crâne d'orques
donc c'est un cétacé on le voit parce
que on voit que c'est un cétacé parce
que là vous avez le trou du de l'évent
qui est ici et donc les maxillaires ici
et les prêts maxillaire au dessus donc
maxillaire près maxillaire qui sont
projetés vers l'arrière par dessus le
crâne
c'est très typique des cétacés l'arcade
du gal qui est très fine
ici vous avez l'oeil donc et puis
évidemment les dents énorme comme ça
c'est c ou à séoul une orque ou une
pseudo work
j'ai pas la prétention de pouvoir faire
la différence mais je dirais plutôt que
c'est une orque hier gagné donc
évidemment la reconstitution en tant qu
crocodile alors en partant du principe
qu'on a déjà vu le crocodile et que du
coup les aliens saurait déjà à quoi
ressemble un crocodile je ne pense pas
qu'il dirait que c'est un crocodile
parce que c'est très très très
différents le crocodile déjà il a le
museau sur le
à l'avant du nez alors que là on a bien
dit que ici et que le nez puisque les
vents c'est l'équivalent du nez chez
cétacés il se trouve au sommet du crâne
donc ici un derrière les yeux les yeux
sont beaucoup trop hauts voyez que les
yeux là ils sont très très basse située
au même niveau que la rangée dentaire
donc là les yeux et devraient se situer
ici en réalité donc pareil je donnerai
un peu plus de crédit à nos aliens en
disant qu' il aurait quand même il y
arriverait quand même un peu mieux que
ça à voir que c'est pas un crocodile pro
cas via l'irak ce le damman aussi comme
on l'appelle donc proches parents des
éléphants petit animal qui ressemble
beaucoup à un rongeur mais qui n'en est
pas un puisque en fait il quand on
regarde ses doigts il n'a pas des
griffes comme les rongeurs mais en fait
il a des sabots donc c'est un set un
proche parent des éléphants qui
s'appelle le damman vous pouvez googlers
bon marché vous que je veux googlers ça
pour vous c'est les vacances
voilà si vous gueulez irak ce c'est ça
que vous trouvez donc tout ça c'est à ça
que ça ressemble à un miracle donc
maintenant matin on est passé la pauvre
petit animal qui ressemble à une
marmotte as donc non en fait bon je vois
bien d'où ça vient à l'idée de lui
coller des immenses dents de sabre ça
vient de sa bon c'est pas des dents de
sabre déjà parce que ce ne sont pas des
canines
ce sont des incisives déjà elles sont
situées sur le spray maxillaire que vous
voyez là
donc ce sont des incisives les dents de
sabre les canines serait situé sur l'os
maxillaire qui est l'os qui vient
derrière là où se trouvent les molaires
donc non déjà c'est pas des dents de
sabre de 2 elles sont plutôt elles sont
pas très affûté cédant 2,3 elles ont
plutôt de trois ce sont des défenses et
non pas des dents de sabre donc elles
n'ont pas d'émail en fait donc la
différence entre une défense c'est dans
normal c'est que les défenses n'ont pas
d'émail donc là on est sur une défense
dépourvu des mailles donc c'est pas
comme les dents de sabre non plus et
ensuite ce serait certainement pas
reconstitués comme un carnivore déjà
parce que vous voyez là il ya les toutes
les incisives pointu là il n'y a pas d'
1 6 point tu la seule il n'y a qu'une
seule paire d'incisives essais les
défenses donc ça c'est pas typique des
carnivores du coup ici vous avez un trou
là parce qu'il ya pas de canines et là
vous avez une belle rangée de grosses
molaires bien carré bien plate donc bien
herbivores et vous avez des muscles
l'instigateur très développé vous avez
des muscles mastic ateurs très
développés qui sont attachés à l'arrière
ici de ceux de ce morceau de mâchoire et
qui donne du coup un ascète à cet animal
une belle bouille viard on doit non
c'est pas un miracle ça ah non non non
non mais là si vous commencez à mettre
des fausses images là on va pas s'en
sortir c'est pas un miracle c'est pas un
miracle du tout ça non cet animal c'est
un qu au cas la belle bouille qui sourit
la c1 qu au cas c'est un marsupial le
d'amont le lait zeerax sait même pas des
marsupiaux cd placentaire la c1
taxonomique fail d'envergure
internationale la c1 taxonomique fail ça
vous fait confondre scarlett johansson
avec un kangourou quoi confondre
ardemment avec un cocasse et c'est
scarlett johansson confondu avec un
kangourou quoi tu te réveilles le matin
tu as pris une cuite tu te réveilles le
matin et penser un kangourou qua non non
non non voilà non là c'est bien c'est
pire que de confondre une loutre avec un
phoque blabla pour le coup au moins
j'étais dans la même famille quoi la
famille decani forme là là non là c'est
moins 12 pour pour portland à moins 12
bon alors suivant on va essayer de pas
scrollé trop bas ce coup là bas ça c'est
alors savent ça a effectivement l'air
d'un monstre je vous le concède
ceci dit derrière le monstre il y a un
animal il y a un coeur est là pour le
coup c'est un chien
donc ça c'est le crâne de
je sais pas exactement de quelle xiam ça
doit être un peu être un bouledogue
peut-être un carlin un de ses chiens
vous savez qu'ils la fassent tellement
aplati qu'il arrive pas à respirer quoi
donc cesser ce genre de chien l'a alors
comment on arrive à voir que c'est un
chien c'est toujours les mêmes indices
déjà à sisyphe canine molaires ça montre
qu'on est en face d'un mammifère les
énormes incisive que vous pouvez voir
bon il y en a quelques unes qui ont été
perdus j'imagine que c'était un vieux
pépère mais voilà il ya des énormes
incisive qui montre que c'est un
carnivore la canine qui est relativement
bien développé et vous avez toujours là
carnassière qui est bien visible à
l'arrière
donc c'est définitivement un carnivore
la dentition qui est plutôt ému c'est
donc on est plutôt du côté cani forme du
plus du côté chien de la force
et après c'est juste la forme du crâne
qu'il ya qu un seul type de cani forme
qui peut avoir une tronche pareil et
c'est les carlins et les les bulldogs
quoi voilà en plus de vous avez les gros
yeux pour le coup qui vous rentre bien
dans l'est dans les yeux ça c'est ça
c'est très très intelligente ce jeu je
plussoie jeu je valide totalement cette
reconstitution
voilà les aliens sont comme ça ils sont
ils sont excellents les aliens je
plussoie totalement suivant je suis
d'accord le crâne
pourquoi cv pourquoi ces vides ils ont
de l'humour oui bah oui un invertébré
n'a pas de crâne donc évidemment vous
pouvez toujours essayer de reconstruire
ses c'est une très bonne leçon ça pour
la paléontologie un l'absence de preuve
n'est pas preuve d'absence on peut
toujours arriver à reconstituer en
partie les mondes fossiles mais tout ce
qui n'est pas préservée n'était pas
forcément absent ça c'est vrai c'est une
bonne leçon ça en fait c'est une très
très bonne leçon de paléontologie cette
page là tu vois pas trop bas pas trop
bas le crâne
alors ça c'est un squelette met d'accord
admettons bon c'est un crâne de
carnivores enfin c'est un crâne c'est un
squelette de carnivore donc des poux
commencé parce que il est dit jti grade
i lady j tigra de ce qui veut dire
qu'ils ne marchent pas sur le bout des
doigts comme un onglet donc quand même
comme la plupart des herbivores il ne
marche pas sur la paume comme comme les
beaucoup de primates comme les écureuils
comme beaucoup de joueurs c'est un dj
tigre had de taille moyenne généralement
les digits et grades de taille moyenne
c'est des carnivores d'une et de deux on
voit que sur le crâne il ya quand même
des grosses canine des grosses des
grosses dents bien pointu que je
suspecte être celle d'un félidés le
crâne en général est plutôt celui d'un
fait l'idée avec un museau relativement
court vous voyez que l'oeil est ici donc
le museau ici est plutôt court alors que
la boîte crânienne est plutôt allongé
donc généralement c'est aussi un truc
qu'on retrouve chez les félidés sauf
chez la loutre de tout à l'heure elle va
pas passer la loutre à aa la honte la
honte soit ma famille la honte sur 9 h
le déshonneur quoi donc comment les
extraterrestres constituerait sa un
tigre d'accord est en fait c'est un chat
ouais enfin on est bien d'accord que on
est bien d'accord que là c'est un peu de
la mauvaise foi quand même hein je veux
dire le à cette distance là sa
différence surtout surtout qu'on n'a pas
de barre d'échelle je veux dire on n'a
aucune idée de la taille du machin moi
j'étais parti sur un grand félin
effectivement mais non apparemment ce
serait un chat je vous avoue que comparé
aux chats tout à l'heure l'oeil est
vachement petit donc tout à l'heure il y
avait pas trop de doutes sur le fait que
c'était un chat parce que l'oeil était
vachement grands là je vous avoue que je
serais plutôt partie sur un jeu plutôt
partie sur un puma
on va dire al'allure général je serais
parti sur un puma ou sur sur quelque
chose comme ça quoi
donc ouais là c'est jamais qu'un groupe
kwa donc les à les extraterrestres pour
le coup serait très malin alors le crâne
ah ben ça c'est intéressant comme crâne
alors qu'est ce qu'on a ici
on a un crâne avec donc des grosses
incisive bien développé donc ça ça fait
typiquement pensée soit un rongeur soit
à un lapin donc déjà on peut d'ores et
déjà exclure tout le reste c'est du
rongeur ou du lapin c'est pas la même
chose
rongeur famille rodès ya enfin ordre
dans sia lapin ordre lagomorphes a donc
c'est très très différent confondra
rongeurs et à la pince et confondre
scarlett johansson avec eux c'est une
bonne question ça avec quoi ça vous fait
confondre ce que le problème c'est que
les seuls animaux qui me que je
visualise sur des machines vous
connaissez peut-être pas forcément donc
c'est confondre scarlett johansson avec
un terme aux terres voilà je vous laisse
google et dermo pts rdr mob terre ou un
scandent anciens aussi vous pouvez
essayer de google et scandant siens mais
vous verrez que ça ressemble pas du tout
à scarlett johansson bref donc là pour
le coup c'est plutôt un rongeur parce
que on a ce trou là cet énorme trou là
c'est le foramen infra orbitaire qui
chez les rongeurs ne fait ne donne pas
que passage au nerf trijumeau il donne
aussi passage en fait aux muscles master
donc le muscle master est tellement
grand qu'il n'a pas la place donc les
rongeurs évidemment comme il ronge
ils ont besoin d'un énorme muscles
mastic ateurs le muscle master et donc
gigantesque et il est tellement grand en
fait qu'il n'ya plus la place sur la sur
l'arcade gigal du coup il va squatter le
maxillaire en passant par le foramen un
froid orbitaire donc donc là pour le
coup ça ça indique clairement qu'on est
face à un rongeur d'alors attend comment
les aliens reconstituerait sas a déjà
l'air de faire peur
[Rires]
c'est dommage c'est dommage il y avait
tellement mieux à faire il y avait
tellement mieux à faire que ça bah non
les aliens ne constituerait pas ça comme
ça alors si je vois je vois ce qu'ils
ont voulu faire en fait c'est parce
qu'il ya un trou là et il ya un trou là
donc il ya plusieurs yeux et là ils ont
près effectivement pris un animal qui
avait trois paires d'yeux alors que là
on pourrait dire qu'il ya effectivement
deux paires d'yeux ccpo faut aller ouais
accordé accordé après il ya beaucoup
trop de dents je le dire quelle que soit
la façon dont vous le regardez là il ya
beaucoup trop de dents sur cette
mâchoire a beaucoup trop d'endroits où
on ne les voit pas sur le crâne donc un
petit peu plus de crédit j'accorderai
aux aliens en disant qu'ils n'auraient
pas mis un troisième oeil et qu'ils
auraient laissé les bonnes dents au bon
endroit
voilà et puis là vous avez un gros trou
pour l'oreille
donc je lui aurais aussi collé des
grosses oreilles là là on manque ça
manque un peu d'oreille là ou alors
c'est le troisième oeil qui va là mais
dans ce cas là les distances sont pas
respectées et voilà un bon petit rongeur
hamster
le crâne donc ça c'est un crâne de chien
c'est un crâne de chien mais j'ai pas
vraiment de raison de vous dire pourquoi
c'est un crâne de chien que j'ai déjà vu
un crâne de chien et que ça ressemble
exactement à ça là j'avoue que je suis
un peu en panne de caractère tout à fait
probant à park j'en ai déjà vu et je
sais que ça ressemble à ça donc on va
dire que voilà pas mal
ouais pas mal
c'est marrant aller c'est marrant vous
la corde ouais ils ont bien c'est quoi
ça c'est un coyote un coyote c'est un
renard je ne suis pas sûr mais d'accord
voit les canidés vendus à bas un
ornithorynque un magnifique
ornithorynque donc on peut voir les yeux
ici là c'est le bec de canard de leur
nid thorenc ici on voit les ce qui
remplace les dents de l'ornithorynque
assez de la kératine en fait ça c'est
pas de c'est pas de la danse et des
petits pavés de kératine qui remplace
les dents donc ça c'est définitivement
un ornithorynque évidemment ils ont pris
le truc le plus moche du monde et comme
jabba le hutt ça marchait pas parce
qu'il n'a pas un long museau bas on a
pris ça on a pris les vaches à l'aide
de star wars alors je suis je suis
d'accord avec en partie avec cette
reconstruction
déjà parce qu'il ya effectivement un
long museau le nez si tu es pas tout à
fait au bout du museau
ce qui est aussi le cas chez
l'ornithorynque et ils reconstruisent
beaucoup de viande sur le sur le museau
alors que leur dit rien quand c'est à un
bec de canard mais mais mais mais à leur
crédit
il faut bien l'admettre que ici vous
avez le foramen infra orbitaire et que
depuis tout à l'heure je vous dis le
foramen infra orbitaire quand il est
grosse et qui avait beaucoup de viande
c'est pas le cacher leur ni tanks
donc là il aurait pu se faire piéger de
la même façon en fait il est il est très
très gros chez l'ornithorynque mais
l'ornithorynque n'a qu'un bay qui a pas
de viande et le forum en fait le foramen
et très gros parce qu'il innerve
effectivement le bec mais le bec et
électro récepteur et ça il n'y a aucun
moyen de le deviner juste avec le crâne
le bec et électro récepteur est donc ce
nerf ce nerf trijumeau en fait il lit
nerv les électro récepteur du bec
donc c'est pour ça qu'il est très très
gros donc il ya une raison quand même à
ça mais ouais là pour là pour le coup je
suis d'accord en fait avec l'idée que se
ferait un extraterrestre de staub est là
parce que effectivement là il n'y a pas
trop moyen de savoir que ce tube est là
aurait pas de beaucoup de viande sur le
nez à part qu'il n'ya pas les muscles
encore une fois il n'ya pas les muscles
clinique et donc petit ornithorynque à
merde je me suis ce pôle est la
reconstitution
bon alors oui je comprends donc ce coup
là c'est ce coup là c'est un phoque
alors on refait le même raisonnement que
tout à l'heure
donc le même raisonnement que tout à
l'heure c'était incisive canine et
molaires donc on est sur un mammifère
des grosses incisive des grosses canine
on est sur un carnivore ouimet dentition
au mode honte avec des dents qui ont
trois cuts speed donc toutes les
molaires sont les mêmes et on 3 q speed
ce qui est typique des pinnipèdes et
enfin des pinnipèdes des otaries et d
et des phoques parce qu'évidemment les
parce que les morses et en conclut fages
ils ont des grosses dents plate ils
n'ont pas du tout les gens comme ça donc
on est soit sur une otarie soit sur un
phoque et absence de casquettes au
dessus de l'oeil
c'est un phoque donc voilà donc là on
sait que c'est un phoque pourquoi parce
que y'a pas d'oreille voilà donc c'est
pas une otarie c'est bien un phoque bien
jouer board tanda ceci n'est pas un
taxonomique fail est-ce qu'on
reconstruise rsa comme ça par contre en
voilà une question qu'elle est bonne
alors il ya il ya un truc intéressant
sur cette reconstruction supposer c'est
que le nez est effectivement rétracter
voyez que le nez il n'est pas au bout du
museau il est rétracté comme sur le
phoque la position des yeux marche
relativement bien il ya la présence de
cette fosse qui me chagrine un peu parce
que là il n'y a pas de fausse mais en
l'occurrence si on admet que c'est la
fausse plus ou moins du muscle labiale
en fait on pourrait partir du principe
que les extraterrestres au lieu
d'interpréter la fosse du muscle labiale
comme une assertion musculaire il aurait
interprété comme un comme une vraie
fausse en fait donc ça pourrait marcher
éventuellement après pourquoi les cornes
et tout ça ça je sais pas à la limite ça
pourrait marcher si ils ont vraiment
aucun moyen de s'imaginer qui si il
pouvait y avoir un muscle mais bon c'est
quand même c'est quand même une fausse
assez évidente donc ça juste imaginer
qu'il y avait un trou là comme ça qui
servait à rien ça me semble bizarre
comme façon de raisonner on va dire le
squelette alors l'exosquelette en
l'occurrence là c'est bon c'est pas
chiant quand on a un exosquelette parce
qu'effectivement le l'exosquelette a
déjà la forme de l'animal le squelette
est à l'extérieur donc il épouse
parfaitement la forme de l'animal donc
on se fait pas chier c'est pareil en
paléontologie
alors là donc ça c'est le crâne d'un
requin marteau qu'on reconnaît très très
bien enfin je veux dire là vous avez la
bouche c'est une bouche typique d'un
requin et puis vous avez les trucs des
deux côtés les yeux sont normalement si
tu es là
c'est pas mal c'est à dire cécile avait
le crâne mais qu'ils avaient mais en
s'imaginant que le crâne était la
totalité de l'animal c'est pas mal c'est
non pas que ce soit jamais arrivée
anomalocaris pendant très longtemps on
en avait que la bouche qui avait une
forme de tranches d'ananas et on n'avait
aucune idée de ce à quoi ça ressemblait
il y en a qui ont proposé que c'était
une méduse un juste parce que c'était
plat est relativement rare on dit quoi
donc
donc non ce n'est pas complètement
impossible qu'on puisse avoir de
l'imagination à ce point
ceci étant dit encore une fois je
donnerais du crédit à mes
extraterrestres en disant que ça c'est
une bouche du cheval donc avec des
belles incisive bien bien plate et bien
herbivores ça c'est quand même des
danses férocement carnivores ensuite si
il avait regardé un petit peu en dessous
là vous avez la boîte crânienne qu'on
voit à travers le palais ici puisque les
requins n'ont pas de palais aussi fier
donc ici on voit directement la boîte
crânienne et s'ils avaient regardé à
l'intérieur de la boîte crânienne il se
serait rendu compte que c'était le
cerveau et donc qu'il avait juste une
tête en fait pas un corps entier donc
j'aurai je donnerai un peu plus de
crédit aux extraterrestres que ça en
disant qu'il aurait peut-être pas et
serait peut-être pas aller jusqu'à
imaginer que c'était un animal entier en
fait ce truc là et c'est effectivement
un requin marteau caisse pour ça c'est
une blague
ce n'est pas un crâne ça c'est un je ne
sais pas c'est une oie c'est une noix de
quelque chose d'une bestiole que je
connais pas et effectivement à squelette
bon bah ça c'est un lapin ça c'est un
lapin comme on le sait déjà bombal
allure générale du squelette les très
longues jambes les très très longues
jambes a donc un animal sauteurs là ils
l'ont remis en position plantigrade ce
qui est plutôt étonnant pour un lapin
c'est bon c'est un lapin qui est couché
du coup on reconnaît bien les lapins en
fait surtout parce que le maxillaire là
vous voyez il ya des petites ombres à
l'intérieur parce que le maxillaire et
pneumatiques en fait il n'est pas là
l'os est perforé par plein de petits
trous et c'est pour ça qu'on a plein de
jeux de petites ombres ici même si la
résolution est pas tip top
on a effectivement les incisives qui
sont très développés qui indique que ces
ou un lapin ou un rongeur et là vous
avez la forme de la mâchoire ici qui est
très typique des sept formes arrondies
là les traits typiques des lapins et on
a aussi une petite casquette au dessus
de l'oeil comme celle et comme chez les
otaries qu'on voit un petit peu aller à
elle ressent un petit peu de ce côté là
bon c'est pas évident évident mais je
vais vous montrer un crâne de lapin vous
allez voir tout de suite pour de lapins
de lièvre ou de 1g pas là prétendent
j'ai pas la prétention à cette distance
de pouvoir faire la différence entre un
appât un lièvre rien c'est bon c'est pas
un pic a par contre ça je peux être sûr
donc là on voit bien le maxillaire
pneumatiques la forme de l'angle de la
mâchoire
les incisives évidemment et et la petite
casquette ici au dessus de l'oeil qu'on
voit un peu mieux la voilà la petite
casquette au dessus de l'oeil ici les
lapins aussi si on avait encore une fois
si on avait meilleure résolution là on
devrait voir une deuxième paire
d'incisives que les rongeurs non pas
dinosaures mais en plus c'est pas
n'importe quel dinosaures c'est l'ado
minus rex que non c'est l'inde aux
raptor pardon c'est l'inde aux raptor
encore une fois honte sur moi ça c'est
l'inde aux raptor sérieusement la cc le
golden goal d'un demi-mille avec la avec
la rangée de doré sur le côté ils ont
pris ça de chez pas de jurassic world
évolution je n'en sais rien non jamais
de l'avion rencontre ont reconstitués
comme ça trop dedans encore une fois les
lapins ils ont pas autant de temps que
ça voyez que tout ça là c'est
basiquement édenté et là aussi donc non
je donne plus de jeu donne plus de
crédit à nos amis extraterrestre il ne
constituerait pas ça comme ça mais
encore une fois
ça pose la question de com quel genre de
revêtement haut mais par dessus ça a
quel peau qu'est ce qu'on met sur la
peau est ce qu'on met les écailles à ce
qu'on ait déplu mais ce qu'on met lui
est ce qu'on met du fleuve là comme ça
ça par contre c'est une vraie question
qu'est ce qu'on ferait si on savait pas
que les lapins avaient deux avec de la
fourrure
au suivant
alors ça c'est un aiai ça c'est un crâne
d'aiai déjà parce que on a vision
binoculaire donc on est face à un
primate
et puis là on a ses danses et ses
petites incisive comme ça dirigé l'une
vers l'autre à la pointe
ça c'est typiquement c'est typiquement
un accueil
donc évidemment on ne peut pas mettre
une photo d'ailleurs sans déconner mais
ceci dit je comprends comment ils en
sont arrivés à ça je comprends vous
comment ils en sont arrivés à ça alors
encore une fois il n'ya pas de museau là
sur votre sur cette reconstitution donc
je donnerais du crédit aux
extraterrestres en disant qu'il n'aurait
pas qu'ils auraient mis un museau les
extraterrestres aurait du coup
probablement fait ressortir un peu plus
les dans la bouche ne serait
probablement pas si petit
regardez la taille de la mâchoire je
veux dire même surtout si on part du
principe qu'ils oublient ils mettent des
jours où je pense pas qu'ils
oublieraient puisque vous voyez là on a
encore une fois une assertion pour le
muscle déjhouqués très visible ici donc
ils oublieraient pas je pense de mettre
des joues meiway est peut-être qu'ils
oublieraient de mettre les joues après
il ya les oreilles les oreilles sont
très grande celle aïe aïe
est-ce qu'on penserait à mettre des
oreilles ça c'est une bonne question
parce que c'est pas et c'est une autre
question ça on sait jamais vraiment quoi
mettre au niveau des oreilles
c'est alors c'est généralement pas un
problème quand on a des mammifères
fossiles
parce que généralement ils ont des
proches parents donc on leur colle les
oreilles de leurs proches parents mais
ça peut devenir un problème quand on a
des signaux dont tu par exemple si nos
dont on sait pas trop si on doit leur
mettre des oreilles ou pas les
mammifères du mésozoïque on sait pas
trop si on doit leur remettre des
pavillons auditifs ou pas donc c'est
vrai que ça pour les oreilles les
oreilles c'est un truc typiquement de
mammifères mais on sait pas depuis quand
en fait donc si ça se trouve
voilà et après jeudi les oreilles mais
c'est pas si évident que ça je dis ça
parce que vous voyez là il ya un bouquin
sur l'inde rico terre qui est sorti il
ya peu
si longtemps que ça et alors là l'image
de couverture est assez elle est assez
éblouissante donc vous voyez c'est le
corps d'anne adrie koster là me mettez
la main sur l'écran la cacher cette
partie là hop cacher cette partie là
voyez ça c'est bien le corps d'un adrie
koster ou para serra terium ballouchy
terium comme vous voulez là c'est la
tête d'une espèce d'éléphant et ça ça
fait rire pas mal de monde ça fait rire
pas mal de monde surtout pour la
couverture d'un bouquin c'est comment
ils en sont arrivés à ça comment ils en
sont arrivés à lui coller des oreilles
d'éléphant sama ça m'a un peu surpris
puisque ben oui le plus proche parent
c'est le rhinocéros
c'est comme c'est écrit sur le titre du
bouquin donc son plus proche parent
c'est le rhinocéros alors pourquoi ils
ont fait ça au lieu de ça ou ça par
exemple voilà une tête plus tôt de
rhinocéros avec des petites oreilles de
rhinocéros alors effectivement à museau
légèrement à m'isoler avec une lèvre
bien flexible mais pas mais une trompe
comme ça en plus une trompe ou les
narines sont pas situés au bout c'est
quel intérêt d'avoir une trompe si les
narines sont pas situés au bout de la
trompe venir donc plutôt voilà c'est
bizarre c'est très bizarre ça comme
comme reconstruction mais c'est pour
vous illustrer quand même que même pour
des animaux pour lesquelles on a des
proches parents modernes
il ya quand même des gens qui sont allés
se poser des questions voilà là c'est la
même image mais en un peu mieux on va
dire on va pas dire que c'est mieux ou
plus réaliste parce qu'on ne sait pas au
final à quoi ça ressemblait nadri côté
rien mais je dire on a que le crâne pour
pour deviner mais bon se disant que
c'est un peu plus quand on parle de
spéculation rationnelle voilà là là je
suis sur de la spéculation pense qu'il
ya spéculation beaucoup plus rationnel
ici que la voilà parce que là on est sur
une spéculation rationnelle qui
spéculent sur la base des proches
parents modernes de l'animal alors que
là là ils se sont basés plus sur un
éléphant donc c'est bizarre c'est très
très très bizarre de se baser sur un
éléphant plutôt que sur un rhinocéros
parce que c'est finalement c'est quand
même vachement loin confondre encore une
fois on va reprendre l'exemple de
scarlett johansson confondra rhinocéros
est un éléphant c'est confondre scarlett
johansson
avec une chauve souris voilà au niveau
distance génétiques non encore pire que
ça c'est confondre scarlett johansson
avec avec avec avec avec un éléphant
parce que c'est la même distance au
final c'est la même distance génétiques
entre un rhinocéros est un éléphant est
en train dumas est un éléphant il ya la
même c'est la même temps d'évolution qui
a eu entre l'ancêtre leurs ancêtres en
commun d'enfants que voilà waouh
alors bon là on a le squelette et on a
la lienne alors la lienne séoul d'en
face et les chiens de suhl je sais pas
exactement comment les appels mais bref
ce sont les gardiens dans ghostbusters
sos fantômes et et non je donnerais du
crédit aux aliens en disant que non
reconstituerait pas ce cet animal la de
cette façon la tête est trop grosse il
ya des cornes
il ya même des cornes sur la mâchoire là
il n'y a pas de rien qui indique qu'il
devait y avoir des cornes sur la tête ni
sur la mâchoire et puis la dentition là
ne colle pas non plus les classes sont à
la part amende et incisif qui sont très
gros cela se sont définitivement des
canines la tête tu es trop large aussi
là c'est plutôt une tête fine et puis
les jambes ici sont pas du tout dans le
bon état donc ça c'est un chien
évidemment je mange on a un petit peu ce
pôle est là la solution là mais je veux
dire c'est un chien à l'évidence bon du
moins un canidé
on peut dire que c'est un canidé parce
que bon on est sur du carnivore avec la
dentition qui va avec la carnassière on
peut pas vraiment voir si c'est mou pas
mais on peut ce qu'on peut voir c'est
que voyez par rapport à tout à l'heure
l'oeil il est là et vous avez
presqu'autant de museau que de boîte
crânienne derrière en fait donc ça c'est
plus typique des canines decani forme se
sait pas c'est pas une règle d'or non
plus mais c'est plus typique des caddies
forme donc après la lure générale est
plutôt celle d'un chien que celle d'un
ours ou d'un blaireau houdart
houdain pinnipèdes voilà donc on n'en
est pas là on est plutôt sur deûle
allure générale on va dire que sur du
sur des caractères bien spécifique donc
pas trop de surprise sur le fait que
c'est un chien
par contre on le reconstitue aurait
jamais de cette façon puis regardez les
proportions les bras sont plus longs que
les jambes alors que la cedh et voilà en
même temps ils l'ont fait plantigrade à
l'avant et digitick grade à l'arrière
alors c'est chelou mais les jambes et
les bras sont à peu près de la même
longueur chez le chien maintenant je
donnerai plus de crédit voilà pour dire
je donnerai plus de crédit à nos
extraterrestres en disant que non en
partant de sa les extraterrestres ferait
pas ça bon on a de nouveau accusé de vol
voilà parce que le crâne il serait trop
long alors on est de nouveau face à un
problème de loutres pourquoi un problème
de loutres parce qu'on est de nouveau
face un petit carnivore grosse incisif
grosse canine apparemment il ya l'air
d'avoir une carnassière la boîte
crânienne et est très longue il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de casquette au
dessus des yeux donc on a encore envie
de dire une otarie oui mais oui mais ça
a l'air très petit ouais je sais pas en
fait y'a pas de ya pas de barre
d'échelle mais c'est parce que c'est à
cause du grain en fait de la photo c'est
voyez là le s'est posé sur une sorte de
tapis on voit que la maille du tapis est
quand même assez grosse comparé au crâne
voilà donc ça m'a l'air d'être un tout
petit crâne et puis là c'est très très
fins qui est aussi indicateurs qu'on est
face à un petit crâne on n'est pas sur
un animal marin
enfin pas on n'est pas sur un animal
aquatique parce que la bulle tympanique
est beaucoup trop grosse ici avec une
oreille ici beaucoup trop grosse alors
que chez les animaux marins l'oreille a
plutôt tendance à se réduire
donc là on était un animal on est sur un
animal qui devait plutôt avoir des
grandes oreilles et qui devait plutôt
vivre je pense dans un milieu ouvert
donc des airs savane plein
je suis pas sûr et donc on est sur du
petit carnivore alors va bien falloir
que je me lance à un moment et j'ai
envie de dire à la forme de la mâchoire
là on a quand même un foramen infra
orbitaire qui est très très gros donc
d'ailleurs encore une fois le ça
marcherait pas pour le xénon meur fin
puisque
ça marcherait pas pour le xénon woerth
pour les mêmes raisons que tout à
l'heure c'est que l'absence de lèvres
alors qu'il ya un gros un foramen
afrobeat air qui indique qu'ils avaient
de la viande ici absence deuil alors que
là il ya une orbite
donc c'est comme tout à l'heure le même
problème que tout à l'heure
et puis absence donné alors qu'il doit y
avoir un l et es et il va falloir que je
me lance
eh ben je vais dire un suricate un
suricate aller a perdu c'était une
belette honte sur moi là deux points de
perdu deux points de perdus sur 23
ouhlala mauvaise moyenne là c'est une
mauvaise magie là c'est très mauvaise
magie à il est intéressant ce crâne dire
alors là là je vais parce que je veux
pas spoiler ce qu'ils ont mis pour les
extraterrestres avec un crâne comme ça
donc là et bien là on a déjà on n'a pas
de canines ni d'incisives d'une molaire
donc on n'est plus sûr du mammifère
on n'est plus sûr du mammifère on est
sur du reptile on est sur du reptile
avec donc un grand deuil donc déjà de la
dentition nous indiquons et sur un
reptile
on voit que les dents là à l'intérieur
de la mâchoire elles sont sur la face
interne de la mâchoire donc on est sur
un squamates parmi les reptiles
on sait aussi que c'est un 10 abside
puisque vous avez la fosse temporal
supérieur fausse temporal inférieur ici
ici le quadra taux du gala la fosse
temporal inférieure est ouverte parce
qu'il ya pas de quadras taux de galles
c'est aussi un caractère de squamates
vous avez ici un très très long oscars
et qui est l'articulation entre le crâne
et la mâchoire
il est très très long ça c'est typique
des squamates aussi parce qu'il ya une
double articulation il ya une
articulation de ce côté-ci et une
articulation de ce côté là et après je
sais que c'est un iguane parce que les
iguanes sont les seuls à avoir cette
cette espèce de truc là l'arrière de la
tête ils ont tous c'était le gros
développement à l'arrière de la tête
d'ailleurs je dis des bêtises je dis one
depuis tout à l'heure mais c'est un
caméléon en fait donc en plus je dis des
bêtises
c'est un caméléon et puis les caméléons
ils ont souvent des ornementations comme
ça donc
[Musique]
donc voilà ça se voit ça en fait sur
leur tête un des caméléons
là je suis plutôt déçu car l'
imagination est là je voyais plutôt un
dragon quelque chose comme ça je pensais
qu'il serait aller un peu plus loin mais
vrai donc on voit bien là sur le
caméléon l'arrière de la tête et pousse
bien la forme du crâne d'ailleurs c'est
aussi pour ça que beaucoup de dinosaures
seront construits avec juste les
écailles sur la tête parce qu'au final
vous avez le crâne vous avez quasiment
la forme de la tête il n'y a guère que
l'oeil qui est très très gros ici et qui
avait voilà ce beaucoup de viande autour
d'une toute petite d'un tout petit oeil
alors qu' on aurait plutôt tendance à
reconstituer un animal avec un gros oeil
spontanément encore qu'il y à des fosses
d'insertion pour les muscles des yeux à
l'intérieur qu'on voit très bien ici et
là donc ouais là là il manque un peu
d'imagination moi j'aurais dit un gros
dragon tu vois quelque chose comme ça
surtout qu'ils n'ont pas mis de barre
d'échelle là il aurait pu et puis elle
est plus franc jeu que ça que juste
mettre un dinosaure de plus quoi un
dinosaure avec plein de cordes ou ça
manque un peu d'imagination
d'autant que les corps ne sont même pas
de la bonne taille sur le nez bonjour
amis un beau dragon a alors ça ça c'est
un cas intéressant c'est un cas très
intéressant ça ça va finir en alien
c'est sûr ça va finir en alien parce que
c'est hyper humanoïdes et en même temps
vachement différent d'un humain donc
généralement ça finit en alien en petits
gris bon bah ce qu'est ce qu'on est on
est face à un tarsier comment on
reconnaît le tarsier bat déjà c'est un
primate parce que une deux incisives
deux paires d'incisives une canine avant
la can initie donc une perdre ainsi de
perdre incisive c'est typique des
primates vision binoculaire c'est
typique des primates aussi est
évidemment la taille des orbites c'est
le tertiaire y'a pas à tortiller la
taille des orbites c'est le quartier et
le tarse y est aussi le seul primate à
avoir le fond des orbites seulement à
moitié fermés là vous voyez cette soirée
soit on est face à un lémurien et les
orbites sont complètement ouverte
l'ariège et du coup on voit le on
pourrait voir le mur là à travers soi on
est face à un singe et chez les singes
donc humain inclut un jeu dire c'en est
face à un singe et dans ce cas là le
fond de l'orbité est complètement fermé
il n'y a pas de petites ouvertures comme
ça juste en bas donc la halle orbite à
moitié fermés c'est aussi typique des
tarsier alors est-ce que j'ai eu raison
à ce qu'ils auraient mis un petit gris
fort gagner gagner gagner gagner gagner
avec ceci dit que le nez trop et trop
petit enfin on le voyait la taille du
nez quand même puis encore une fois il
ya un musée où il ya un petit musée
et donc c'est effectivement ça c'est ça
m'a pas l'air du tout d'être à tartiers
savoir contraint les yeux sont trop
petits regardez la taille des orbites
par rapport au museau la regardez la
taille des orbites par rapport au museau
je ne crois pas que ce soit non là je
pense qu'ils se sont plantés là pour le
coup c'est pas un hasard si ce truc là
le crâne
bon bah c'est encore un félidé grosse
grosse incisif grosse canine énorme
énorme carnassière donc on est déjà à
sisyphe canines des molaires mammifères
grosse canine grosse incisive carnivores
carnassière qui nous indique aussi que
c'est un carnivore l'oeil qui est très
très grand avec ici un museau très court
et qui est beaucoup plus court que la
boîte crânienne c'est du félidé c'est du
félidé il n'y a pas trop il n'y a pas
trop à se soucier reconnaître qu'elle
fait l'idée maintenant surtout sans
barre d'échelle pour savoir quel temps
il fait ce crâne c'est plutôt compliqué
l'oeil est un très grand je dirais que
c'est un petit félin pas un grand félin
donc pas un lion ou 1
ceci dit ça peut être un lion parce
qu'il n'y a pas du tout n'est pas si il
ya peut-être il ya que 3 prémolaires
maintenant je sais pas il ya que deux
prémolaires la has et peut-être c'est
peut-être un grand quand même hein mais
allez on va se jeter je vais dire comme
tout à l'heure un puma
mme aubry nous hormis exactement le même
[Rires]
d'ailleurs prennent le même kranja
reprennent le même truc bon bah voilà
et il pas loin ils ont bien l'ex je sais
pas si c'est un lynx tout pour être tout
à fait honnête je ne sais pas c'est un
petit chat c'est pas un grand chat c'est
un petit chat donc au moins j'avais au
moins ça de de bon ah ça c'est
intéressant ça ça c'est intéressant
parce que c'est flou j'arrive même pas
voir ce que c'est pour le coup là haut
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est un truc
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
waouh alors bon on va opérer par on va
opérer par par par élimination j'ai
envie de dire alors on a une énorme
on a une énorme incisive bien pointu ici
donc jusqu'à présent on a dit que les
grosses incisive bien pointues elles
sont pas prêts en plus y'a pas les dents
elles sont pas toutes là mais là on a
quand même et on va quand même les
fausses des dents qui nous indiquait
qu'il y avait des grosses incisif sur le
dessus donc on va dire que c'est des
grosses grosses d'incisives donc on va
dire que c'est un carnivore un carnivore
qui a le museau très rétracter on va on
voit que ça c'est la cavité nasale donc
le museau est très très rétracter donc
on est face à un carnivore plutôt
aquatique du coup avec avec un gros gros
nez un gros gros nez comme ça ah ah
et là on a des dents à l'arrière donc ça
c'est les molaires du coup alors ça du
coup c'était pas l'incisif c'était une
canine six as et les molaires donc ça
c'est la canine mais les incisives là on
a quand même une incisive le trou
d'incisives là qui est vachement gros
mais si ça c'est les molaires les
molaires sont toutes les mêmes
et quand les molaires sont toutes les
mêmes chez les carnivores ça veut dire
qu'on regarde un pinnipèdes et du coup
ci c'est un pinnipèdes avec un si gros
nez ça doit être un un éléphant de mer
un éléphant de mer qui n'ont rien à voir
d'ailleurs avec ni avec les éléphants à
part du fait qu'ils ont une genre de
trompes ni avec les siréniens qui sont
des cousins des éléphants qui vivent
dans la mer mais qui sont pas des
éléphants de mer
ceux là on les appelle des vaches de mer
donc là si c'est un pinnipèdes fassis
est un carnivore pinnipèdes enfin
aquatique ça doit être un pinnipèdes et
là on se confirme va aller je place mes
jetons sur éléphants de mer est là là je
risque vraiment d'avoir l'air con si
c'est pas ça genre c'est un rhinocéros
[Rires]
tu viens de confondre scarlett johansson
avec un lapin bref comment la lienne
visualiserez cet animal a alors ça c
était rod au taurus ça c'est une
reconstruction des terreaux d'auto aux
russes qui est un dinosaure
ornithischiens du début du jurassique et
à mon avis non je pense là là je vais
vraiment donner beaucoup de crédit aux
extraterrestres en disant que non parce
que là je veux dire il ya quand même un
mec là il ya un bec sur la mâchoire
inférieure alors que là le voyez que la
mâchoire inférieure se termine par les
incisives donc les voilà ça 7dans là ne
peut pas être l'équivalent de 7 dans la
et puis là vous voyez l'assertion là
pour les muscles sont tellement évident
ici et puis là c'est le gros fort amène
ici indique clairement qu'il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup de viande là donc non
je vais je vais donner beaucoup de
crédit à mes amis à mes amis
extraterrestres en disant que à mon avis
dirait pas non il n'y aurait pas dans
cette direction au yes we la honte la
honte de moi
la honte de -27 à il reste plus que deux
bon oui bon ben là c'est une tortue je
veux dire il ya une carapace et bien
évidemment c'est une tortue ninja quoi
je crois même que c'est une tortue une
sna pink turtle en anglais donc une
tortue alligator en français voilà donc
ça je pense que c'est une tortue
alligator
rien qu à l'ornementation du crâne voyez
comme le bec et aiguisé et tout ça c'est
une tortue je pense que c'est une tortue
alligator évidemment la tortue la tortue
ninja pour les extraterrestres c'était
inévitable
bien que là pour le coup le modèle de
tortues ninja
ils ont pris est un peu bizarre parce
que là les yeux enfin le nez beaucoup
trop hauts les yeux sont beaucoup trop
binoculaire et le feront enfin l'avant
de la tête et beaucoup trop plein et il
ya beaucoup trop de dents aussi là pour
le coup les extraterrestres il serait
pas qu on à ce point là au point de
colle et des dents à une tortue surtout
en ayant le crâne devant les yeux donc
non là pour le coup les extraterrestres
ne ferait pas ça du tout lalala
l'annoncé de la discrimination anti
extra terrestre je m'inscris en faux
et puis en plus y'a même pas de bec non
non non non et j'ai une arcade jug alors
regardez moi ça et il a une arcade du
gal
c'est une tortue avec une arcade du gala
lors qu'elle allait il n'y a pas de
fausse temporal comment voulez vous
qu'ils aient une arcade du gal non non
je suis désolé de mes amis
extraterrestres ne se trompent réparé ce
point et voilà notre mille attendu bon
le dernier ont fini sur un wind ont fini
sur un wind allez on y croit
attention aaa intéressant là c'est très
intéressant parce que ce n'est pas un
mammifère
pourquoi ce n'est pas un mammifère bas
parce qu'il n'ya pas d'un sixième de
canines et de et de mollesse toutes les
danses ont les mêmes donc c'est un
reptile
c'est un reptile avec un crâne très très
allégée donc c'est probablement à
squamates parce que les squamates ils
ont les fausses temporal tellement
grande phase la fosse temporal inférieur
tellement grande qu'il reste plus rien
d'ailleurs on voit que là il ya le los
du jus gala qui ferment l'oeil ici qui
rebiquent et qui va pas jusqu'à
l'arrière donc c'est comme tout à
l'heure c'est comme tout à l'heure pour
le caméléon que j'ai malencontreusement
appelé à higuain
donc c'est comme pour ta de tout à
l'heure le caméléon n'a pas de bar ici
qui ferme la fosse temporal on a un très
long hausse
carrez qui s'articule à la fois avec le
crâne et avec la mandibule donc une
double articulation qu'on appelle
stripped au style it donc typique des
squames at on est définitivement sur un
squamates et après la la forme de l'os
maxillaire comme ça puis le fait le fait
qu'ils aient beaucoup beaucoup de
d'articuler enfin que le crâne soit
hyper alléger ses du var en voilà et
puis c'est un carnivore évidemment
donc là on est sur du warrant
typiquement je mets mes billes sur var
en as assez intéressant d'avoir choisi
les espèces de bestioles dans king kong
dans le dernier king kong
c'est vrai parce qu'en face c'est
intéressant parce qu'ils ont
effectivement je pense qu'ils ont
définitivement utiliser un crâne de
warrants comme modèle parce que ça
effectivement définitivement cette forme
là une forme très très pointue avec des
dents très acérées mais qui sont toutes
les mêmes
après les proportions sont pas bonnes au
niveau des yeux là le museau est trop
long par rapport à la taille de l'oeil
donc il ya des proportions qui divergent
mais mais je pense qu'ils ont
définitivement utiliser un crâne de
warrants pour ça ouais et puis se sont
plantés c'est pas marrant ça c'est un
gay cause c'est un gecko léopard ça
c'est pas un vent ça va pas du tout ce
crâne d'un gecko léopard
voilà ça c'est un crâne de gecko léopard
vous voyez que le museau et moins faim -
triangulaire ça a pas grand chose à voir
et puis la dentition voyez que c'est
plein de petites dents alors que le
warrant là il a beaucoup de grosses
dents donc voilà si je tape monitor
moniteur lizard skull qui est warrants
en anglais et là on est beaucoup plus
cela suppose un voyage je retrouve même
exactement la même image que celle
qu'ils ont utilisés sans aucun problème
donc voila c'était la petite activité de
l'été tout en détente tout en finesse
donc j'ai eu 26 sur 28
honte sur moi honte sur ma famille il va
falloir que je refasse un des baumes kg
pénitence afin d'expliquer mes erreurs
mais ça ce sera pour la rentrée
ah les bonnes vacances et amusez vous
bien